التي لقبت بالمدينه الحمراء تعتبر من اهم
الوجهات السياحيه في العالم العربي وهذه
ابرز معالم مراكش التي تستقطب السياح صاحب
جامع الفن التي شيدت في نفس عهد التشييد
المدينه في القرن الخامس الميلادي سوق
مراكش بمتجريه المتنوعه التي تقدم التحف
والانتكات النادره والملابس الشعبيه
بالاضافه الى السوق الحرفيين المخصص
الصناعات اليدويه التقليديه حديقه ماجوريل
وهي حديقه رائعه تستقبل محبين النباتات
والازهار النادره قصر الباهيه وهو من
المعالم التاريخيه المميزه بالمدينه ومتحف
العراق حيث يجب محبي الموضه متعتهم اثناء
زيارته ومتحف درس الصعيد ويعتبر تحفه
معماريه تستحق ان تكون ضمن اهم المعالم
السياحيه في مراكش للراغبين بالتعرف على
العماره المغربيه المدينه القديمه او كما
يطلق عليها اسم المدينه العتيقه ضمت الى
قائمه اليونسكو ولترات العالمي لكونها احد
مواقع التراث ذات الاهميه التاريخيه
الكبيره مسجد الكتيبه وحي القصبه التي
يمثل تاريخ المدينه وعظمتها فهذا المسجد
العتيق يتميز بتجل العماره الاسلاميه التي
تظهر بصوره واضحه على الابنيه القديمه
بمدينه مراكش العتيقه حي المدابغ ويمكن
زيارته للتعرف على كيفيه صناعه المنتجات
الجلديه